mark you and I were on air both Saturday
and Sunday as the president headed out
to his golf course for a couple of
rounds on the Lynx he got a lot of flack
on that for Twitter people talking about
what he said about President Obama who
golfed as well and now how is the
president responding today yeah twitter
is not always a kind place and we
certainly saw a lot of criticism after
President Trump made those trips both on
Saturday and Sunday out to his Golf Club
in Virginia was the first time he had
gone out there since early March now
he's addressing that criticism head-on
and where else but on Twitter writing
quote some stories about the fact that
in order to get outside and perhaps even
a little exercise I played golf over the
weekend the fake and totally corrupt
news make it sound like a mortal sin I
knew this would happen
the president in those same set of
tweets then criticized his predecessor
President Obama for golfing during his
presidency it's something we see in
President Trump talked a lot about over
the years Lalah yeah certainly during
President Obama's presidency when
President Obama would golf President
Trump had a lot to say about it then
then candidate Trump Mark Meredith North
Lawn of the White House Mark back to you
as news warrants thank you